liang a aidé vous remplissez un
questionnaire quel est il
je suis la marraine d'une grande enquête
qui débute aujourd'hui à strasbourg et
je rempli le questionnaire
d'ailleurs monsieur le mental va vous
dire tous les secrets ce questionnaire
est en effet un questionnaire parmi tant
d'autres qui rentre dans une très grande
enquête qui concerne le coeur des
français
grande enquête qui utilisent les
méthodes les plus scientifiques pour
essayer de déterminer pour chaque
individu quel est l'homme dont ils
rêvent
et quel est l'homme qu'il rêve de lui
qu'elle est la femme qui rêve celui qui
va t'en faire de ces questionnaires bien
se questionner une fois une fois remplis
chaque personne va l'envoyer à
l'ordinateur et 7,7 ordinateur va mettre
en mémoire un très très très grand
nombre de questionnaires si bien que la
france entière va être en mémoire dans
cet ordinateur et compte tenu du
questionnaire de chacun cet ordinateur
va faire une réponse une réponse qui va
se présenter sous la forme d'une lettre
personnalisée il va vous dire chers
michel cher pierre cher rené et dans
cette lettre qui aura environ 140
s'inclinent ce qui est énorme ça fait
près de 80 cm de long cette lettre
parlera de la personne qui a rempli le
questionnaire de la personne qu'on
recherche
en amour et de la personne qui vous
recherche en amont en fin de compte de
la personnalité de la personne de la
personnalité de la personne est
maintenant sur un plan beaucoup plus
large
ce que nous visons ces deux d'établir en
quelque sorte la carte du tendre
française une carte du tendre qui nous
permettra de dire eh bien à strasbourg
il y a énormément de blonde de la ned 60
qui recherchent des hommes bruns
qui ont fait des études secondaires et
qui aime les sports d'hiver par exemple
voilà ce que nous recherchons nous
cherchons à déterminer une sorte de
typologie du coeur de la france